hello guys and welcome to today's video
on essential equipment for gardening
whether you are a seasoned Gardener or
just starting out having the right tools
can make a big difference in the success
of your gardening endeavors
in this video we will be discussing some
of the essential equipment you will need
for gardening
trowel
the first item on our list is a hand
this small handheld tool is perfect for
planting small plants digging small
holes for seeds and transplanting
seedlings
a good hand trowel will have a
comfortable grip and a sturdy blade that
won't Bend or break easily
pruning shears
the next item on our list is pruning
shears
these are essential for maintaining the
health and appearance of your plants by
removing dead or damaged branches and
stems
a good pair of pruning shears should be
sharp easy to grip and have a locking
mechanism to keep the blades closed when
not in use
garden gloves
gardening can be tough on your hands so
a good pair of garden gloves is a must
have
look for gloves that are made of durable
materials have a comfortable fit and are
breathable to prevent your hands from
getting too sweaty
watering can water is essential for the
health of your plants and a watering can
makes it easy to give them the right
amount of water
look for Akin with a comfortable grip a
large enough capacity to water all your
plants and a spout that allows you to
control the flow of water
Garden Fork
a garden Fork is an essential tool for
turning soil and breaking up clumps of
dirt
it is also useful for removing weeds and
aerating the soil to improve drainage
look for a garden fork with sturdy times
and a comfortable grip
wheelbarrow
a wheelbarrow is a useful tool for
transporting soil mulch plants and other
heavy items around your garden look for
a wheelbarrow with a sturdy frame a
comfortable grip and a large capacity to
hold all your gardening supplies
in conclusion these are just a few of
the essential tools you will need for
gardening
investing in high quality tools will
make gardening easier more efficient and
more enjoyable
remember to always wear appropriate
safety gear when using any gardening
equipment
thank you for watching and don't forget
to like the video also do subscribe our
channel to be updated happy gardening